völlig übertriebene gewalt oder war es
wirklich nötig security einsatz am
münchner hauptbahnhof drei
sicherheitsmitarbeiter knien auf einem
mann der zuvor eine frau angerempelt
haben soll und drücken ihre knie auf
seinen körper auf seinen hals es sind
bilder die an george floyd erinnern
fixieren ihnen am boden völlig
übertriebene gewalt oder ein notwendiger
einsatz gegen randalierer der bahn haben
wir diese frage gestellt antworten
wollten sie aber nicht
sie knien auf ihn halten ihm den mund zu
diese aufnahmen stammen vom münchner
hauptbahnhof
dort ist eine kontrolle der
bahnsicherheit eskaliert mitarbeiter des
sicherheitsdienstes rücken einen mann zu
boden der zuvor eine mitarbeiterin an
der schulter angerempelt haben soll die
aufnahmen zeigen ein heftiges vorgehen
der security-mitarbeiter ein mann ein
slowake liegt am boden wird von den
bahnchefs fixiert videoaufnahmen zeigen
später der mann ist unschuldig hat
nichts getan ein polizist zu bild am
einfachsten wäre es gewesen die
beteiligten hätten auf die bundespolizei
gewartet dann wäre es vermutlich nicht
eskaliert kritisch ist es wenn druck auf
den hals oder oberkörper kommt und mund
und nase zugehalten werden da sind wir
ja in diesem fall aber nicht
gleichzeitig die bundespolizei hat
ermittlungen wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung gegen die bahn
mitarbeiter aufgenommen die deutsche
bahn wollte sich auf bild anfrage
wegen der laufenden ermittlungen nicht
äußern
[Musik]